on retrouve le ministre des finances
belmondo dans nos studios d'ottawa avant
soir monsieur morneau bonsoir et je suis
très heureux d'être là que vous
aujourd'hui
écoutez ça nous fait plaisir cela dit
vous devez répondre à plusieurs
critiques aujourd'hui parce que la
hausse des déficits ça ne fait pas
l'unanimité c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire comment vous justifiez ça aux
canadiens comme j'ai dit aujourd'hui
c'est très important ou des bouts
d'avoir une mise à jour économique qui
qui explique notre situation économique
est bien sûr notre approche est de faire
des investissements dans les médias les
canadiens y compris les québécoises et
des québécois
ça c'est très important nous avons une
approche qui qui était très bien pour
pour l'économie pendant la dernière
quatre ans et nous sommes à la vie que
c'est important de continuer avec notre
proche de faire des investissements
c'est de cette façon rhône niveau de
croissance économique et une bonne
situation au niveau de chômage
et qu'est-ce qui cette fois ci fait
gonfler le déficit monsieur mono donc à
l' déficit vous pouvez voir avec notre
mise à jour économique que le déficit
diminue chaque année et pour nous les
choses important nous voulons garder
notre bon situation au niveau de notre
bilan
ça veut dire que nous avons une niveau
de dette par rapport à notre économie
qui est qui déjeunent le plus bas dans
l'est entre les pays g7 et chaque année
nous nous allons diminuer le niveau de
dette par notre économie ça c'est très
important
on a avec ça une approche qui va assurer
que nous pouvons réagir si c'est
nécessaire s'il ya des défis économiques
et ça c'est ça c'est très important
aussi on a une cote de crédit triple à
et ça c'est aussi important pour la
confiance donc un autre proche c'est
c'est clair que ça fonctionne et
et on est une bonne situation au niveau
de notre économie c'est vrai qu'en
termes du taux d'endettement par rapport
à la taille de l'économie la tendance
est baissière mais vous avez quand même
relevé un peu à la hausse la
comparativement à vos prévisions du
budget et on se demande quel est le
message en fait parce que d'un côté vous
vanter la croissance économique qui est
quand même assez vigoureuse
mais de l'autre côté vous nous dites
qu'on doit continuer de stimuler
l'économie au point de gonfler les
difficile qu'est ce qu'on doit
comprendre mais sûrement les changements
dans l'edf si tu es vraiment cause de
notre investissement dans les cliniques
les lignes sa vie à une réduction
d'impôt l'année prochaine par exemple on
va avoir trois milliards de dollars en
plus dans les poches des canadiennes et
canadiens et dans 2023 ça va être 6
milliards de dollars donc ça c'est
l'investissement on peut le faire avec
notre notre situation parce qu'avec une
bombe hilare on peut faire des
investissements sais c'est c'est clair
que ça c'est la proche qui était
considéré par par d'autres gouvernements
mais aussi par le management de théories
fade aussi des les autres c'est une
bonne position pour notre économie en ce
moment cela dit il ya par exemple des
chambres de commerce aujourd'hui qui
souligne que dans une situation où
l'économie progresse on sort d'une
période de croissance assez vive
on aurait dû se retrouver dans une
situation où les rentrées d'argent sont
plus importantes où il y aurait pu même
y avoir des surplus pourquoi on n'en est
pas là à ottawa parce que notre approche
est écrit avec les investissements mais
mais quand même notre approche
le déficit diminue chaque année dans
notre prévision de forecast cinq ans ça
veut dire que le dernier en l2 c'est à
peu près 11 milliards de dollars et le
niveau des dettes rapport notre économie
diminue aussi donc ça va être
vingt neuf personnes c'est vraiment le
plus bas entre le g7 en tant que c'est
une bonne position je sais qu'il ya des
gens qui considère la situation dans la
province mais ça c'est vraiment dans une
situation développement
oui justin trudeau vous a confié le
mandat monsieur mono de vous préparer un
ralentissement possible de l'économie
avec des déficits déjà important est ce
que vous avez la marge de manoeuvre pour
faire ça à mon avis oui ce qu'on a fait
on a assuré le niveau de dette d'adp
mignot et ça c'est important on va
assurer que notre cas de crédit est
encore trop plat et en même temps on va
avoir un niveau de confiance et le
possibilité de d'avoir tout lé réseau
social s'il ya un défi économique mais
mais finalement le position est très
important sionneau niveau de croissance
si on a une situation où le chômage est
le plus bas à prendre quarante ans ça
c'est une bonne position pour n'importe
quoi donc ça c'est ça c'est pourquoi
nous avons à choisir le prochain assez
prudent mais avec les exercices mans oui
bon il est clair que la situation
économique du canada est enviable en ce
moment vous avez parlé du taux de
chômage les salaires est hétéro mais on
immerge quand même de dix ans de
croissance
ça va se terminer un jour si une
récession devait survenir est ce qu'il
faut comprendre que vous déficit
augmenterait encore par exemple on verra
le heureusement maintenant on a vous
savez que nous chaque année qu'on a une
mise à jour économique nous y lisons les
provisions de d2 secteur privé les
économistes le secteur privé on a ou 14
provisions et chaque chacune entre eux
était aux halles vie que nous sommes
dans une bonne position au niveau de
croissance à saint cloud les six plus
grands bancs des jardins de caisse de
dépôt ça veut dire que c'est une bonne
idée de faire des investissements
maintenant d'être prudent on a été en
même temps pas assurer que nous allons
avoir une approche qui va assurer que
nos dépenses diminuent aussi à
et ça c'est ça c'est une bonne situation
ouais vous parlez de réduction de
dépenses d'ailleurs le premier ministre
vous a aussi confié le mandat de réduire
progressivement l'endettement du canada
est-ce que vous aurez les moyens de
réaliser toutes vos promesses dans ce
contexte là on peut le faire on peut
avec avec nos investissements on peut en
même temps diminué notre dette tant pour
l'économie
ça c'est assez clairement possible mais
vraiment on va être prêt s'il ya des
filles dans l'avenir et c'est toujours
une situation où on doit faire des
investissements en doit être prudent et
je crois que nous avons pris la proche
qui est qui est vraiment à trop près
pour notre situation il ya peut-être un
élément qui va vous aider dans les
prochains mois mais c'est mon nom le
fait qu'on a signé une nouvelle mouture
de l'acm l'accord de libre-échange dans
quelle mesure ça va stimuler l'économie
c'est vrai la situation avec la li na va
être bon pour pour les investissements
et en même temps que ses banques les
américains les chinois on trouvait une
une
pas une solution mais ils sont dans une
meilleure situation ce moment mais quand
même ça c'est ça c'est dans nos
provisions donc s'il ya une situation
qui est un peu mieux avec plus d
investissements dans le secteur privé
ça va être bon mais on est maintenant
ouvert qu'une proche qui va être bon
n'importe où n'importe où les
changements dans le dans le niveau des
changes vous allez devoir défendre cette
mise à jour économique dans les
prochaines jours mais sur mon nom vous
est talonné entre autres par les
conservateurs qui veulent une cible pour
le retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
est-ce que vous avez ça en tête pour
l'instant pour l'instant vous avez vous
notre approche les cultures à mon avis
c'est une c'est pas vraiment une bonne
approche il
il donne sens de danizy et et aux
canadiennes comme j'ai dit il ya 14
provisions du secteur privé et chaque à
prévision est positif laissons les gens
qui sont négatifs sur les quatre
voitures et un certain temps on pense
que ça c'est pas vraiment bon pour pour
l'économie ça c'est vraiment trop bon
pour les cliniques nikki qui sont en
train de considérer ce qu'on va faire
pour un noël
donc à mon avis c'est presque et rust
irresponsable a pour eux de trouver une
piste comme ça oui monsieur mono merci
beaucoup pour vos explications
merci beaucoup à voir à voir